humans are built to serve consider my
new book built to serve if you're not
happy it's because you're not serving
either serving the world or serving the
the closest people to you but if you're
not happy it's because you're not
serving and so I want to help other
people who are struggling with belief
like I was and still do believe in
themselves more and me playing small and
not doing videos and not speaking on
stage doesn't serve anybody it's selfish
it's selfish for me not to get up and do
it so every time I get on a camera
before I do interviews or when I do
stage work or when I'm making my videos
even though I've done 6 000 videos from
my YouTube channel I still get a little
nervous inside before making the videos
because my biggest fear is disappointing
people my biggest fear is I'm going to
show up and not bring value and people
are going to be disappointed in what I
made but that's not a good enough reason
I'm here to serve and so is everybody
else and being afraid is not a good
enough reason not to act need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because I need it I need it for
me because I don't wake up every day and
say yes let's go conquer the world now I
wake up and and I need that external
motivation to match my internal
motivation when I see somebody who's
doing amazing things it makes me just
want to play a bigger game and so I hope
that today's video makes you want to
play a bigger game too because your
message matters and let's get it out to
the world so today let's learn from me
and my team's take on my top 10 rules of
success enjoy
rule number two is build rapport we
could take these businesses in different
directions like if the goal is is
speaking the key thing is getting to
know the people who are hosting these
events who are the people putting it on
and build a relationship with them the
easiest way to do that is a Biz Dev show
so you have them on your show you
already have a podcast it's great I
don't know how you're selecting the
guests to come on your show but now it's
with an intent to I want to get speaking
gigs
from this person or their Network like
are you already thinking about that or
how have you picked I mean the reason I
started the podcast was to have a big
personal development brand podcast and
so my concern in that is that a lot of
the people I get on now are speakers
authors you know coaches that stuff
which I understand I can't Market to
them because they're in the same game
but not to dilute the podcast if that
makes sense so you have two choices
there one you start a different show
geared just towards this or two you find
an angle that it feels right in your
heart yeah to have them on yeah so if
you're looking who's putting on events
for entrepreneurs you can go research
all the events for entrepreneurs uh or
even like I don't know if you go into
sales or if you go into MLM
yeah great so all of those conferences
or people who are selling Insurance like
all of these things they're like pseudo
entrepreneurs insurance people are yeah
you're kind of an unsure but yeah not
way less risk yeah right yeah real
estate same thing you're an entrepreneur
but there's like a support system around
it so there's lots of events happening
around those things yeah
you find lots of all the events you find
Melissa who's organizing them you invite
them on your show to be a guest they
care about personal development yeah
otherwise they wouldn't be putting on
these events true yeah why put them
event for entrepreneur or is there real
estate professionals or MLM industry or
whatever yeah they care about this stuff
do you personally connect with them
enough that it feels right in your heart
to have them on the show you can make a
judgment call yeah whether it's a fit
for the main show or you start a
different show around it yeah but that's
gonna be your fastest path to get
speaking gigs right talk to the people
who are hosting the events yeah other
speakers and authors
not that they see you as competition
yeah but they're they're probably going
to take the deals that they like to buy
for sure you know and they may not
remember you or past like they have lots
of entrepreneur friends and speaker
friends that you may not be the first
person that they call yeah if they want
to turn it down that's right yeah right
so it's not that it's not possible it's
just a much longer road yeah so if you
want to be strategic and get we want to
get deals for our speaking gig like
that's the fastest way to do it yeah and
it's not that difficult to execute rule
number three is stay consistent for
someone you want create this map your
morning routine yeah you know it's one
thing to just listen or to see what
other people are doing but how can they
actually create one for themselves so I
split in the two the first part is what
has made you bold powerful confident
alive right it's happened to you you've
felt it it's just not consistent that's
the problem for most of us it's not
consistent of these moments of boldness
like I can do anything and then you wake
up tomorrow's like I can't do that thing
anymore and we just live in the world of
I can't do it but you feel like you're
capable of more but you're afraid to
take action so in those moments where
you have felt boldness what did you do
just before did you did you have a
conversation did you meditate prayer
like whatever the thing was yeah then
that's not even pulling from somebody
else that's you you've already felt
boldness what happened how did you do it
now try to plan that in your morning
routine and that can be different for
other people for me it's helping people
and so the easiest way to do it is by
going live on Instagram then it's
pulling from different people to see
what are they doing and how can you
apply it I love small tests yeah we were
talking about General before yeah before
going live so a lot of people do
journaling Tim ferriss's journaling like
lots of successful entrepreneurs do
drilling it's like okay I'm gonna great
idea to action I'm huge when I get an
idea go do something about it yes well
number four is enjoy the work doing the
work is torture for most people
if you look at my channel we're doing
three videos a day for a lot of people
jumping into my work schedule would be
torture for them it would be torturous
like it's just too much work right and
that's great and it's like I love it
though like I chose I chose this life I
love the work I'm doing I love being
here talking to dick you know this is
this is good this is happy for me other
people like all right I gotta talk to
dick I gotta be on a live stream I'm
panicking I'm freaking out you put me in
that landscaping job I had a landscaping
job I would die man like I hated that
job
but for other people it's like you know
what I love being outside I love I love
being fit I love my friends here like
it's just to be successful in anything
you have to enjoy the work that you're
doing and not everything is great you
know not every day is roses you're gonna
have a lot of crap that you deal with
and the thing that gets you through all
the crap is just the love for the
process and so I think it's still
important to have goals it's nice but
more important than the goal is the
journey to get there also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is create an
impact tell us what is one thing you do
every morning to set your day up for
success
um
I've got a bunch I'm trying to think
like what would be a really cool or
different one
um
thinking about service right like
it's so easy to get complacent as an
achiever
so thinking about like what I do today
has to matter I want to create something
meaningful that's going to help impact
other people's lives today and putting
that pressure like tomorrow is a
different day today something important
has to happen giving has to be a part of
the morning routine
oh oh okay
I might have to think about that yeah
whether that's whether that's actually
given in terms of like
you're going to take a call with
somebody and Mentor them uh or you're
going to buy the coffee for the person
behind you in line or you're just gonna
meditate and pray for somebody like I'm
thinking of somebody in my head and I
want them to have love today and you're
like focusing your energy on supporting
somebody else
giving will make you feel so much more
alive and has to be a part of your daily
routine rule number six is build a good
morning routine what your current
morning routine looks like so I go
through five s's uh sing Sun sore sweat
scare so sing I put on music right away
and any song that will get you like if
it came on you'd have to bounce and
you'd have to sing right yeah
um
so right now there's a there's a Chinese
wrap that I did it's a Chinese song that
I did a rap in English on top of yeah
and so I play that every morning
um Chinese rap is like dance or is it
really straight up like hardcore rap uh
I'm rapping yeah to a Chinese song So
this woman who's rapping and I sped her
up and then I'm rapping over the
Parts where she's not singing that was a
fun little project that I worked on
um so I like it makes me move so I I'm
rapping to my own song every morning
while it comes on but whatever song gets
you up and ready to go because we wake
up and you know you're tired and
starting your day and so music is the
fastest way to change your state like as
soon as it comes on in five seconds you
can barely be feeling better right oh
yeah and there's no one Magical song
it's whatever it is for you and
the audience
um then Sun so I like to get outside so
we got two dogs they're in here with us
today I like to get outside outside just
to get some fresh air on my face we're
in Toronto's December there's not a lot
of sun happening right now but just just
getting out of your environment even if
you work from home the the walk from
just your bedroom to the office you can
carry with that still the tired energy
of the bedroom right so get outside get
some fresh air even if it's
um just go out on the balcony and just
take in some sun for a little bit
another nature mother nature makes a
difference then soar so this is the most
important part what is the thing that
you need to do every day that makes you
feel bold powerful Unstoppable confident
alive whatever that thing is do it first
thing in the morning
instead of waiting like maybe it's
listening to the paper Paradise podcast
or watching the video series now it's
happening if that's a thing then then
you watch it every morning you listen to
it every morning
um
most of us don't have enough intention
behind the day yeah and so I know it's
part of what you do in the morning too
but for me it's I go live on Instagram
so service if I feel like the work that
I'm doing matters is important I'm
serving somebody it makes me more amped
up for the day so I'll go live on
Instagram every morning and people join
in from around the world asking
questions and I help them and quick half
hour
um and that's what I need to do so other
people maybe it's meditation maybe it's
prayer maybe it's something like
anything whatever the thing is that
makes you feel bold powerful confident
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel bold and Powerful
your your year is going to look totally
different like where you are in one year
will be totally different than where you
are right now amen
um and then the last two are just sweat
and scare so I'll do a workout and then
hop into a cold shower because like what
do you like to do for working out
um usually I'll do a 100 push-ups 100
squats what am I doing now 100 push-ups
hundred squats and 100 jumping jacks
yeah and then you do like the Wim Hof
the whole like cold hot that's it uh not
hot just cold just cold just cold yeah
there's no hot in the Wim Hof no no I
mean like the cold like the whole the
the Heat and coolness like you get
really worked out like sweaty oh yeah
you do the cool then jump into the cold
yeah rule number seven is cut out
negativity everybody has an off day but
it seems like you never do and I think
that and I'm sure you still do but when
you're on in front of the camera you're
doing it for the viewers you know what I
mean you're you're putting your selfish
you know bad day I guess aside and
you're focusing on the product and I
think that's awesome and that's really
attractive to me as a viewer that you're
willing to put in the commitment to spit
out free videos a day you know what I
mean yeah you know I uh I suffocate
negativity in my life it happens you
know
be it maybe my wife isn't happy in the
morning or maybe some of my team is is
pissed off when they started the day or
whatever right my natural reaction is
one to like try to avoid that situation
right for that time and then just I just
get so excited I don't know my default
is if there's negativity in my life I
need to suffocate it not give it any
oxygen and go the other way I don't know
where that comes from but it's not hard
to get up for it's not hard to get up
for this like I'm talking to dick I'm
pumped let's do it you know even if
something crappy happened just before it
doesn't matter I'm ready to go when I'm
making the videos for the channel it's
the same thing like it's easy to get
it's least it's easy for me to get all
excited about it because again it's tied
into the work that I do and and why I
you know the why of what I do try to
help entrepreneurs I believe
entrepreneurs are going to solve all the
major world problems not not
corporations and not you know not Banks
and not governments it's entrepreneurs
and so if my work
uh adds a little bit half a percent to
make the difference for a dick or
whoever to go out and push a little bit
harder that's meaningful to me and so I
try to take that with me when I'm going
into filming day absolutely and just
suffocating that you're like you have to
you have to suffocate negativity out to
focus Heaven I think rule number eight
is learn to manage your time you are
making 80 videos in one day you know so
yeah cool uh basically all the videos
for a month and one day
um do one do you still do that and two
um what's the logic behind that and
where do you find the time management
for something like that because that's
one of my uh one of my big downfalls I'm
not so good with time management that's
something I'm learning myself yeah so
I don't do 80 a day anymore that's when
I was filming once a month I film once a
week now and so we'll cut that back to
20 ish videos a week
um more because I'm spending more time
on each of the videos and my team is
preparing things for me that that were
not a month ahead on uh for the time
management it's just
your your actions need to map to your
ambitions
and so you have Ambitions and not just
business Ambitions life Ambitions like I
don't know if you're married or not or
kids or not or but whatever your life
Ambitions are
then I I default to looking at my
calendar
and I say okay I look at my week next
week if I did the things that are in my
calendar for next week am I moving
closer to hitting my ambitions or not
so if I'm if I'm making videos then yeah
but if I spend a week and there's no
videos happening then no I'm not I'm not
getting closer to my missions
and so if you think that your time
management is an issue now you know it
only gets harder as you grow bigger like
if you I have 24 people on my team it's
harder you know like I gotta manage all
these people on top of managing myself
uh and so why not remind myself of
whatever I'm doing right now whatever
challenge I think that's in front of me
I tell myself this is just a warm-up
like this is just a warm-up I'm capable
of more I'm capable of more than what
I'm facing right now because we feel
like the current problem is overwhelming
then that's the limit of what you're
capable of doing so this is just a
warm-up
then I look at uh I look at my calendar
and I look at my goals and I see how do
I how do I match these things up
uh I'm a I'm a huge believer and this
may not work for you but I chunk my days
so Thursday is my public facing day you
know I we're talking on the Thursday I
don't know when you guys are going to
launch this thing but I'm an introvert
and so that may not come across you may
not believe me but I am and and I need
to get up for for public I call this
public facing day so I need to get up
for my interviews and it's been all day
interviews and podcasts and hangouts and
and meetups and that's my Thursday every
day
and I like that because I have a really
hard time switching tasks like to talk
to you guys and be all fired up and
energetic and then go and write my book
and then come back and then do another
interview like I I can't the energy
level it's doable but it just sucks so
much for me that it's better for me to
say in one zone for the day I find that
super helpful rule number nine is know
when to let go how can people out there
you know discover for themselves when to
actually make that call to let go as
someone who wants to make things like
happen and make them a success how do
you know when to actually let go of
something you let go when you don't love
it anymore
business a relationship if you don't
love it you should let go
as soon as possible
um and most people fall into Zoo camps
one
they quit too soon they still love it
doesn't see a lot of entrepreneurs they
still love their business but it's not
working out and so they quit on it this
is why I went back to my business
because I still loved it if you quit on
it too soon and you still love it you're
going to regret that your whole life
yeah you're gonna 10 years 20 years 40
years whatever you can look back and say
I cut it I could have done a little more
yeah I could I quit too soon and so
if you still love it but it hasn't
worked out yet you have to keep going
otherwise you're going to regret it and
use that as fuel
the flip side is a lot of people who
stay in the thing for too long when
they're when they stop loving it people
stay in relationships too long when
they've stopped loving that they stay in
businesses for too long when they stop
loving it because they've had some
Success With It
you're not gonna see in a crappy
business forever if the business has
taken off but then you stop loving it
and you feel like you bought yourself a
job when you quit ASAP yeah like sell it
to somebody else and move on because
you're never going to win doing work
that you hate yeah so while you still
have one foot in the pool of like it's
just okay I don't hate it I don't love
it can you tweak it so that you can love
it or is it time to move on and go do
something else
um
this is what I do on the micro and the
macro always
I still love making YouTube videos I'm
I'm 6 000 videos in 10 years and I still
love it but the day that I stopped
liking making videos if I have to go to
my camera be like I'm I don't know I'm
not feeling it that's it done
yeah done like I'll say hey you want to
take my YouTube channel you know try to
sell it move on or something else
because I'm never going to win doing
work that I hate yeah and that's a big
decision and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
face your fears is there a habit that
you formed that helped you that helps
you break through that introversion and
make those videos every single day
uh so yeah so one
default in the service so I remember I
was uh
late last year I was speaking in front
of a couple thousand people in Phoenix
and I I blanked out 10 minutes before
going on stage I blanked out I forgot
what I was going to say and in my head
like oh my God Brendan burchard and Ian
graciosi invited me to come and speak at
their events and I'm speaking after Eric
Thomas and and I'm I'm blank and I just
imagine myself getting on stage and
having a meltdown and just letting
everybody down and what I did was I I
peeked from backstage to the audience
and reminded myself it's not even about
me it's about them like I'm here for
them stop being so selfish get out of
your way you've got nunchuck and help
them and go out there and serve and so
the serving gives me the strength to
overcome the the anxiety and stress
plus I built an identity around if I say
scary difficult or hard that means I
have to do it
you've got a great idea
you know it can change the world you
know it could have a big impact you know
it could change the fortunes of yourself
your family the people around you you've
got a great idea you know what can work
you know it can work
the problem is you don't know if it can
work for you you believe in the idea but
you don't believe in yourself and so
here's what's happened why well it's
because you've tried and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and you maybe saw a little bit
tiny results but then you lose the
motivation and and you stop you've never
stayed with anything long enough to
actually let it see results and so you
built up this pattern inside yourself
that says I can't do it the idea is
great but I can't do it that's really at
the core if you really believe that you
could do it and you really believed in
the idea you'd be doing it and crushing
it so it's the biggest difference is why
lack of belief is the world's biggest
problem the only thing you're missing is
actual sustained momentum against your
ideas because if you believe that you
could do it you'd be out there doing it
you believe in your idea
and how it could change the world which
you don't believe in your own abilities
to do it
now this is where we have to start
talking about making decisions with your
head versus your heart
so your head only understands a world
that exists your head is logical it's
practical and so whatever has been done
can be done again right it's logical and
so if you've got a job at some company
you know you can make X thousands of
dollars a year that's that's safe that's
logical that's practical you know what
can be done it exists other people have
done it too
you compound that with people telling
you to do the safe thing right go get a
job go take the safe path go take the
safe route and so there's a lot of
outside forces especially fear generated
that keep you on a small path keep you
on the safe path and it's not
necessarily wrong it's not malicious
they're not trying to hurt you
it's just fear-based and so it's small
you never create amazing things when
you're living in a fear-based state and
that's what you're doing when you make
big decisions with your head
because your head only understands a
practical world that currently exists
now your heart your heart's a different
story your heart can create something
that's ever existed before your heart is
where all the artists lives all the all
the game changers live all the people
who end up making massive change in the
world that's where they live they're
creating something new they say I see
something that other people don't see
and I can go create it that's heart
you're creating something that hasn't
existed before that doesn't make sense
that's not logical that's not practical
there's nothing to tell you that this
could work but you feel that it can work
that's where I know you guys are at if
you're watching this channel you're
watching this video that's where I know
you're at the problem is living inside
your head instead of living inside your
heart
so what happens is you'll have some days
where you're living in your heart you
have some days when you feel bold
motivated excited feeling like you're
capable like maybe you could actually do
this you'll have some days I'm gonna
switch my hand my hand's getting tired
I'm holding the video you'll have some
things where you'll actually feel that
way like maybe I can I can be the person
I am bold maybe you watch a video maybe
just wake up and you get inspired you
had a great dream something happens you
have this moment where you just feel
bold powerful and stopper and say
today's my day I'm gonna go off and do
it and crush it right we've all had
those moments
but then you wake up the next day and
you're back to being in your head
telling yourself I can't do this I
didn't go to school for this I don't
have the money for this I don't have the
talent for this I'm not good enough for
this I'm I'm not brave enough or
creatures enough for this right that's
all you're ahead talking to yourself
when you haven't fully decided
on something big what ends up happening
is you're heading your heart fight
so if you haven't fully decided that you
want to start this business that you
want to hit your 10 million subscribers
on YouTube that you want to fill in a
blank your big crazy ambitious goal when
you haven't fully decided on it your
head and your heart are going to fight
they should fight
because it's not logical it's not safe
it's not practical if it was it wouldn't
be a big idea your big amazing bold
ideas are not logical they're not
practical and they're not safe
and so your head is always going to say
whoa whoa whoa slow down this is scary
and most of the time you're gonna listen
to your head and the people around you
will tell you listen to your head
what you need to do is fully decide what
you need to do is decide that this is
going to happen that it's not an option
anymore that there's no maybe I'll do it
maybe I won't your heart has to decide
the big decisions in your life treat you
go move to that other country or other
City should you go marry that person or
not should you go take that job or not
should you go start that business or not
big decisions with your heart and then
you use your head to help you figure out
the how
I always find it so funny when people
are thinking well should I do that
business or not or should I marry that
person or not they make a they make a
list or make a checklist
and you write down pros and cons right
never make a decision that's big in your
life based off of objective pros and
cons because you're making it using the
wrong part of your body
because you might really love somebody
and you come with all these lists and
you got
80 80 cons on that list and only one pro
or maybe that one pro is all you need
same thing with the business there's a
million reasons why your business is not
going to work out you sit there and make
a list of of pros and cons there should
be way more cons there's a million
reasons why you're not going to win an
eight why you will and the people who go
off and win only focus on the eight
making a list of pros and cons to help
you make big decisions in life is one of
the stupidest things you can do
straight up
now your head is very important
your head
helps you accomplish your goals but only
once your heart's decided
so your heart allows you to make the big
decisions I want this to happen in my
life no negotiation this is going to
happen
and then from there you use your head to
figure out how to do it
right once your head is not fighting in
your heart once your head is understood
oh he's serious she's serious okay crap
how do we actually make this happen now
that's when you use your head because
you're a smart person and you need your
head of line to help you accomplish your
big goals so if I want to go off and
build my YouTube channel and get 10
million subscribers that's happening
when I first started YouTube 11 years
ago there was no educational content
there were no 15 minute videos on
YouTube it was it was all memes and and
stupid videos and cats and
just not this not this at all
and it took me too long to listen to my
heart quite frankly you know I loved it
and so I kept doing it and and you know
part of my own back for myself was that
thankfully I kept going I wasn't as
consistent as I am now but I kept going
I didn't give up even though there were
no signs that I would have success right
my first video got three comments in one
year and one was my mom one was my
sister and one was some random dude I
wasn't getting traction I was still
looking back at some of my old videos
yesterday and a lot of them no no
comments right like one video 35 views
zero comments man I spent a lot of time
making that video
and so I kept going
because there was something inside me
that said I need to keep doing this
I wish I could kept going faster and
it's my wish for you too right now with
your business with your idea with your
crazy goals I wish you keep going but I
wish it'd go faster on it that you
decide with your heart to say I am
making this happen
you say head listen to me we're making
this happen now you're the smart one
help me figure out how to actually do it
so to get to my 10 million subscribers
how do I do it
and every day I'm using my brain to help
me do it and hopefully you are too
when your head and your heart are
fighting when your goals your Ambitions
your dreams
are fighting every day what you think is
practical logical possible you're just
going to be stuck
very slow growth very some momentum
knowing you're capable of more but just
stuck because you're fighting yourself
the biggest problem is you're just
fighting yourself but when you can let
go when you can say my heart is going to
help me make the big decisions in my
life
and my head's going to help me figure
out how
magical things start to happen and
that's my wish for you most
entrepreneurs never win on social media
because you're not focused you post
everywhere every now and then with
content that is below what you're
capable of making chances are you
wouldn't even subscribe to you on your
own channels if you weren't you if you
wouldn't subscribe to you you can't
expect others to subscribe to you either
we're gonna fix that in this video so I
make all my content for me I want to
spread more believe in myself and in
doing that I then share it with the
world and and thankfully you guys watch
it you guys enjoy it and I can build a
business off of it but even if nobody
else liked it I'd be making it just for
myself so that I had the content because
this is my own personal development
professional growth series and so I love
learning from Gary I love being around
Gary I love being around Steve and while
we don't have a lot of content on AP
giannini but I love I love being around
you know while my parents don't have a
YouTube channel either Howard Schultz
Kanye West I love I love being around
more successful people Mission driven
entrepreneurs who are trying to make a
change in the world when I'm around it
it pulls me up it makes me want to do
bigger things and so I'm inspired by my
own content when I'm when I'm going to
Instagram and I'm posting a story part
of my morning routine every morning is I
post a story if you see the black and
white pictures it's the current
iteration right now I'll take a picture
of myself and I'll have a message on top
of it'll say the day and then a message
that's a message for me
it's a message that I need to remind
myself of so just before doing the
picture I'll think what do I need to do
it's not even about sharing it's about
what do I want for myself what do I need
to remind myself of today right what do
I need to remind myself of today so that
I show up that I step up that I don't
Coast I don't just take it easy that I
live to my potential today today today
today today right today matters and so
I'll make that message and share it and
then hopefully it touches and inspires
other people as well
that's what's missing from so many
people who are creating content you're
creating content that is one way too
self-promotional you're creating content
that it barely speaks to yourself and
you're just posting it and you feel
crushed under the weight of having to
manage all these different social media
accounts and none of them doing well and
then you ask why am I not growing and
why am I getting followers and why am I
getting the results that I need so I'm a
big believer in being able to have the
accounts everywhere but not actually
being consistently posting everywhere
because I'd actually rather have you
focus on one platform at a time make it
amazing make a crush start winning there
before you expand and build a team and
go to the other platforms but at the
core is you have to be posting content
whether it's videos written podcasts
write audio whatever the format is you
have to be posting content that you're
proud of you have to be posting content
just like any other product or service
if you're selling a product or service
you want to be able to recommend it to
your mom
if she had that problem if she needed
your product or service you would
recommend it to her because you believe
in it so much right you have to believe
in what you're doing you have to believe
in what you're making not just because
my one word is belief but because it's
actually important so would you follow
you are you proud of the work that
you're putting up even though you know
you're capable of more yes great but are
you proud of what you made is that the
was what you posted today the best the
best of what you could do right now
given your current capabilities
resources and skill set yes awesome keep
going no
work it work harder Today show up you
can choose at any moment
positivity you can choose at any moment
gratitude you can choose at any moment
service you can choose to change your
mindset in in an instant if you wanted
to the challenge is we're so living in
our subconscious mode that we don't we
don't catch it soon enough we don't
think the action that we're proud of and
then we regret it you know we regret it
later on this morning I woke up really
early I'm very tired I woke up at 3 45
a.m for some reason don't know why uh
look at my look at my watch like 3 45
a.m what oh man okay try to go back to
sleep toss turn for about an hour and
then I got up like okay you know it's 4
45 it's almost five you know let's let's
get up and I got to work and started
doing things and then the crash hit me
the crash hit me just not enough sleep
and everything inside me wanted to shut
down you know I wanted to just take a
complete break not do my walk in the
morning not not take the dogs out while
the dogs have to go out but not do my
routine not do any of my usual stuff not
record videos today's a Tuesday we're
gonna record it's video recording day
and it's in these moments those trying
times that you have to decide who you
want to be you have to decide if you
want to choose to be positive choose to
live in gratitude choose to live in
productivity choose live in service or
not what would the future you think of
your actions right now
and I think 95 of the time the answer is
to push a little harder move the brake
line forward right where where you would
normally take a break move that forward
just a little bit move the brake line
forward a touch
and five percent of the time you have to
be more gentle on yourself
when my family dog passed away when I
broke my neck when you know all sorts of
things have happened to me just like
they've happened to you sometimes the
answer is to give yourself a little more
grace
to recognize how far you've come
everything that you've done with the
limited amount of resources and time
that you have
but I think if we default to that then
we default to stay in stock and staying
small because life is going to throw so
many different challenges at you
so I think 95 of the time that's the
five percent right five percent of time
you give yourself more grace you let
yourself off the hook you take the day
off you do whatever you need especially
if you're struggling with grief
if you're struggling with grief I think
you just have to work your way through
it you have to give yourself a lot of
Grace and a lot of time and and it will
get better and and just please don't go
through it alone
but almost everything else
usually the answer is to keep going
because it'll make you more proud
because you're teaching yourself that
you stand up to obstacles then you
overcome
so this morning I woke up I got out of
bed I was instantly productive like okay
I'm wired for whatever reason here we go
let's go answering my Discord messages
if you're not on Discord Evan
carmichael.biz I'm there every morning
it's super fun answering questions it's
such a great community so I did my
Discord I looked at the responding to my
emails and Twitter and
um I got all my work done super early
then the crash hits and then Nina wakes
up
and it's time to make videos and
I don't want to make videos
you know I'm I'm tired I feel like I'm
gonna let myself down and I feel like
I'm Gonna Let You Down is yawn's answer
not that I don't want to make videos
because I don't enjoy them I feel like
it won't be at my best and then I won't
I won't create something that I'm proud
of and I'm gonna let you guys down
that's really the internal narrative you
know I'm gonna create a subpar product
and people who watch are gonna be
disappointed because
I take it as a big responsibility that
you know some of you start your day
every day with one of my videos that
means a lot to me it's not a burden but
a responsibility that I take and I want
to make something that I'm proud of and
that helps you improve your life today
at least gives you a little kick start
you know like let's go let's have a
great day I want to be able to bring
that energy and and I I was worried that
this morning I wouldn't be able to do it
but you know what that's not a good
enough reason
it's not a good enough reason
as long as you believe those reasons you
will never create anything great because
if you wait to have the right energy the
perfect timing the right amount of sleep
the the perfect cell phone or video
camera with the perfect microphone and
you know
it just it will never happen you will
never create anything great
and so I had to remind myself of that
because you can choose positivity at any
moment you can choose service you can
choose gratitude you can choose
productivity at any moment you can
choose it if you want to if you really
want to you can instead of defaulting to
the negative patterns and so Nina got up
I told her I was tired told I had a
rough night she said she slept super
well
it's like oh that's really that's really
bad but I slept so well the great well
I'm very happy for you but I'm very
tired right now and
um
right away then that's okay so when are
when are we going out
because Nina's shopping at Costco I mean
I'm in the Costco parking lot I think
you can't make content like I'm sitting
here in the Costco parking lot filming
videos for you guys and I asked her when
are we going out when are you gonna when
do you want to go shopping because I'm
gonna get my phone ready and I'm gonna
make some videos
and in that instant I decided and then
committing to her made it happen
and here I am in the car making the
videos happen and hopefully there's
there's something good and I'm not
disappointing you guys but I'm making
myself proud at the very least
when you show up when the world's
against you or when you've had a rough
day or when you don't feel like it or
when you got a nasty comment or you're
in a weird mood for whatever reason you
still show up like when it's hard
when it's hard and you still show up
that's when you build the most self-love
and self-belief
self-confidence that's where it comes
from doing difficult things
and what it does is it reinforces that
as your identity
that this is who you become so the next
time something comes up you can handle
it aim a little bit more because they're
moving the brake line forward
it's a really slippery slope to fall
down with every time you come up against
something difficult you don't do it
even if other people are telling you how
great you are that you can do it if you
tell yourself that you can't do it then
the next time it comes up you reinforce
it you can't do it and you can't do it
and you can't do it and what you've
built is an automatic pattern of you
don't follow through that you can't do
it that when you set a goal you're not
going to follow through on it you know
you're going to start and then you're
going to stop that when something gets
hard you know you're going to give up on
it or that you're going to quit in a
couple days because that's the pattern
that you built to yourself and the
pattern becomes the identity
right if you want to switch your
identity it's totally possible
you could you could be the person who
always follows through you could be the
person who always steps up you could be
the person who always delivers you could
be the person who always brings it best
you could be that person you may not
believe that yet but you can be that
person so how do you get there
how does that become your new identity
there are two things that really matter
first is to be around other people who
are like that
one of the reasons why I was able to get
up and do this today was because
I watch John astrath and Steve Jobs and
Oprah Winfrey and these people every day
now I happen to know John Ashraf he's
become a friend uh I don't know Steve
Jobs or Oprah Winfrey
um I don't know Oprah yet so we'll see
Steve I've missed my chance
but hanging around them even if it's
virtually even if you you don't know who
John you don't you can't call him up and
ask him a question or you can't call up
Oprah great you can still learn from
them you can still be around them and
the more that you see other people doing
things the more you want to go do it
yourself have you ever been to a movie
and you got inspired and you see
somebody win the race like yeah the
underdog you like I love the underdog
stories you ever seen Underdog go off
and win and then it makes you want to go
not run a race but do your thing like
you've ever been inspired by somebody
else's
overcoming of obstacles story
right
so it's the same thing if you're around
successful people
and you see how they're doing it and you
see how they rise up against the
obstacles in their in their life it
gives you encouragement and hope and
belief that you can too where most of
the people that we're surrounded by
are already giving up they gave they're
not even trying they gave up years ago
right and so when we're at our weakest
moments
when we're around people or consuming
content that reinforces our negative
beliefs
the people say okay yeah yeah just take
a break yeah don't do this you weren't
meant to do this anyway like why did you
think you could ever do this just go and
and play a computer game or just go and
watch some you know trash TV right
just gonna get distracted for the day
pretend like you're doing stuff but you
know you're not doing anything that's
going to make you proud right just
scroll through Instagram all day like
everybody else
right when you're around that then it's
so easy for you to fall down that rabbit
hole when you're not at your A-game so
you can you can manufacture by being
around the people again if you don't
know them personally then just in your
environment some videos you watch is why
it's why I make this content that I can
introduce you to people and and keep
bringing you
ideas and belief that hopefully inspires
you daily to lift you up when when you
might be having a rough day
so that's step one step two is you have
to then do something people say
motivation doesn't last well that's true
but
the point of motivation isn't for it to
last the point of motivation is to give
you the courage to go to the thing so
I'm I'm waking up this morning early
right Nina's still sleeping she wakes up
but before she wakes up while I'm doing
my work while I'm hanging on Discord
first the discord's super fun and
connect with entrepreneurs and so it's
it's already getting me in in a good
mood
and then I started watching videos from
my own top 10 Channel
so as I'm working I've got who do I
listen to today
um I had Bill Gates on
uh we'll head your Bezos on
uh I had an old Richard Branson one on
and their voices are are in my head as
I'm working and so then when Nina gets
up it's like okay let's go let's go to
work because I had Richard Branson and
Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates in my ear this
morning right and I don't know any of
them personally
and so you could do that too right but
the whole point of that motivation is
then to give you the courage to go Act
so by listening to them in the morning
listen to them is not enough right
that's not enough you got all inspired
and motivated to not do anything
listen to them then gave me the boldness
to say Evan you need to make videos
today you said you're gonna do it let's
go do it I know you're afraid of
disappointing people you're gonna make
it the best you can let's go
because I imagine what would Bill Gates
tell me and what would Jeff Bezos tell
me what would Richard Branson tell me
they tell me something like that I think
I hope I don't think they're gonna say
you know what just quit probably not
right
and then that got me to go out and now
I'm here and I'm making the content I'm
doing the thing
so it's the motivation that you need to
inject into yourself
plus the action
and when you do that enough you start to
build the new habit so instead of the
pattern being I don't follow through I
always quit I always get up you start to
build a new pattern that says
I rise to the occasion I overcome these
obstacles I defeat that little voice
inside my head I call it the little man
I beat the little man
when you do that consistently then that
becomes your new default pattern that
the next challenge that comes in you say
okay let's go what's next I'm ready I
want the next Mountain let's go climbing
right
so it's totally possible but it starts
with the belief that at any point
you can choose positivity at any point
you can choose gratitude at any point
you can choose service no matter what's
going on in your life right now there
are millions of people who have it way
worse than you
and you can choose
the light
and you can choose to help
and you can choose to inspire
and doing that will not only serve the
world but make you a lot more proud of
yourself too the whole point of being an
entrepreneur is to create your own
future that's why we start our own
businesses we want to build a new world
we want to be the change that we want to
see right why do you start a company why
do you become an entrepreneur because
there's a problem in the world that you
don't like that you want to fix and you
want to see it change that's right
that's why we do what we do the
challenge is how do you consistently
believe in it you know because you have
these moments these days when you love
it and you're on top of the world and
you're on fire and you're motivated and
you can do this and then most days
you'll wake up and feel like who am I I
can't do this I'm not good enough and
it's not going to happen right does it
happen to you
it's this roller coaster ride of ups and
downs of emotion and just belief that
it's possible for you I got asked
yesterday
uh how did you make so many great
contacts with huge people at the
beginning of your career and the answer
is I didn't I didn't I struggled at the
beginning I was nervous and shy and
Afraid and felt not good enough and
never reached out to people it was a
long journey one of the only reasons why
I had any level of successes I just kept
going you know five years in and having
seven thousand subscribers I just I just
kept going I just kept making and what I
started entrepreneurship thought
leadership at 22 when I started making
content 22 I'm now 42 by the time this
video comes up so 20 years of making
content you know eventually you you make
some connections and get good at
something but hopefully the process can
be a lot faster for you
and the way through it is I think the
environment's like okay how do you fix
it well environment how do you
consistently believe in yourself is the
environment it's what you're surrounding
yourself with it's the people in your
life it's the videos you're watching
it's the content you're consuming it's
the people you follow on Instagram it's
the environment
that when you are around the people that
make you feel like things are possible
you will you will start to feel like
things are possible it's like whoever is
more confident wins so the if you're
around people who are constantly
negative telling you you can't do it
gave up on their dreams the chances of
you
being able to go chase your dreams
around those people is is really low
it's not impossible but it's really low
and I think the the people who killed
the most dreams are the people around
this right your parents your friends
your environment your community it
killed your dreams and ultimately yes
it's your responsibility but hanging
around them and injecting their not not
that they're haters or or bad people
just they're limited thinking and their
unhappiness right they're hurt they're
they're struggling themselves they don't
like their own life and they're scared
they feel trapped and so when you're in
that position of fear and trapped and
scared you don't make good decisions and
you also don't give great advice and so
how do we fix it a couple things that uh
I wish I did earlier and so maybe you
can use this as counsel to help you
believe in yourself more consistently so
number one is to limit access or cut out
the people who are feeding you
negativity if you're hanging around
people who
just make you feel worse about yourself
that any time you talk about your career
your dreams or what you want to build
they tell you that it can't be done that
it's not possible then then limit access
or just cut those people out of your
life it's just not worth it and I say
give the option because you know maybe
that's your mom telling you that maybe
that's maybe that's somebody close to
you telling you that and some people do
take the step to cut their parents at it
that may not be how far you ought to go
but at least limiting access so that if
you're gonna hang out with your mom
you're just not talking about your
career you're just not talking about
your businesses hopefully other things
that you can connect on besides uh just
what you're doing for a living or what
your goals are right so cut those people
out or limit access severely
so that you don't feel so negative all
the time I think it's really important
okay so that then creates a void that
pray okay well not who am I hanging out
with because if you actually didn't
audit of the people in your life you'll
probably find that most of the people
are not the ones that fill you up you're
the ones filling other people up
so we need to start finding people who
do fill us up so step two is to then
join groups and to be around people and
to be around the communities that are at
least like-minded you know as somebody
who's introverted and shy myself it can
be really hard and I think as adults it
can be really hard to uh to make new
friends you know we're not going to
school anymore it's like we hard to
break into new communities and so the
easiest way to do that especially if
you're introverted and shy like me is to
join communities so for me I joined uh
salsa dance school that I later bought
that's how I met my wife Nina I would
join entrepreneur clubs I would join
if I wanted to meet new people I would
join anything that I'm interested in
right I'd look for any entrepreneur
conferences personal development events
or clubs uh any book signings you know
just looking at trying to trying to
start to connect with people who are
more optimistic
and more happy and more positive and
just try to be around them more often
and the goal of going to an event like
that isn't to even necessarily learn
something you know I think it's just to
be able to connect with people and if
you go networking events you go to a
conference or some kind of personal
development session
hopefully you're learning something but
make the goal to just try to meet
somebody you know like there's one
person here who might be the friend that
you need who might be the the business
partner that you need might be the
co-founder that you need there's one
person here that might be everything
that you need and you don't need to know
all thousand people here you just have
to make one meaningful connection that
maybe that turns into a mastermind or
business partner or coffee meetups that
can allow you to sustain the momentum
and the belief that is possible
that being around somebody else where
there's you know one plus one equals 48
because the energy you create together
and the way to do that audit for
yourself is just to think about when I
leave this person do I feel more or less
alive do I have more less energy do I
have more or less belief in myself and
when you have the people around you who
make you have more energy and more
belief in yourself then you're more
likely to go out and create your own
future and create the world that you
want to create right where most of the
people again we are pouring love and
energy into them and that's amazing and
keep doing that and that's service and
you should that's awesome but
um that can't be
the only people in your life you know
because then you just are pointing to
others and nobody's pointing to you and
so we need to start to add in those
people and and they they're out there
they're out there they're for sure out
there I see it all the time in movement
makers that's my that's my membership
group for people who want to be thought
leaders and we meet every two weeks and
I train them and I help them and more
important than even just the education
or knowledge they get from me is the
connection the connection and Community
to each other where they're going live
together there's certain businesses
together they're sitting there making
content you know in their garage or
their basement or their office
uh their home in their kitchen and their
family might be saying what are you
doing making these YouTube videos are
you crazy and now they're around to the
people who are doing the same thing as
them and it just breathes life and hope
and possibility because you've got a
great
heart and a great soul and great
opportunities in front of you and you
want to serve and it can happen it it
can happen it can't happen for you
but again your environment probably
doesn't support it and so it's now
making instead of blaming the
environment and blaming your parents and
everybody else it's making a conscious
choice to change the environment so
again step one is to remove or limit
access of the people who are making you
feel worse about yourself when you talk
about your dreams and your goals and
your Ambitions step two is to supplement
in new people who to do make you feel
better who make you feel more alive and
again whether you're going to an event
or conferences or joining a group like
mover makers but you're part of a
community so it's not just you doing it
all on your own
honestly it's probably my biggest
mistake when I was starting my journey
is just trying to do everything myself
mostly out of fear and insecurity
um I'm being shy and afraid but
hopefully you can get there a lot faster
and that propels your growth forward and
then number three is be really conscious
of what you're feeding into your mind
with the content you consume and so I
think we have this wonderful opportunity
on a on a daily basis to choose
education or choose entertainment or
choose
creating a new world that we want and
and consuming the knowledge that allows
us to build it or escaping a world that
we don't like anymore like if you see a
problem in the world you have a problem
in your life do you choose to fix it to
work towards it or do you choose to just
kind of ignore and try to shut off the
world right most people will try to shut
off the world just be entertained as
opposed to no we got to fix this we
gotta we gotta do something about this
and so think about the videos you watch
you're watching this video so you're
already on the path but do an audit of
everybody that you follow
do an audit of the channels that you
subscribe to do not have where you're
spending your time and see how much of
it how many of the channels that you
subscribe to on YouTube how many videos
that you watch on YouTube are helping
you build a better future for yourself
our training to be a better person we're
giving you the skills and the knowledge
to actually go and make that change
versus how many videos are you watching
that are just pure entertainment or just
shutting off your brain and shutting off
the world and pretending like the
problems that you've gotten and you want
to solve don't exist right and I'm not
suggesting that you
never have entertainment
just switch the ratio
if you want to change the world if you
want to create a new future for yourself
your family for the people around you if
you actually want to do that then you
have to start to change what you're
feeding into your mind and again this
channel is a great start you're all the
way through this video so you're already
on the path and
and I mean it's amazing it's worth
celebrating you know high five to
yourself there congratulations and it's
a consistency that matters the most so
what are you doing tomorrow what are you
doing the next day what videos are you
watching the day after that what videos
are you watching next week and next
month
and making that consistent because again
it's easy to get excited as
entrepreneurs it's easy to get excited
and have one day where you feel on top
of the world and amazing and holy cow
can do so much and so many opportunities
and then it's easy again the next day
wake up and feel hopeless and impossible
and who are you to do this and I can't
do that and there's no way that it's
going to happen and why did I think this
is what a stupid decision right we beat
ourselves up and so that consistency in
the environment is the thing that will
make a difference let me tell you this
if you were hanging around people even
just one person who was always working
out who was always fit
they would even without them telling you
you would become more fit you would you
would work out more because you're
around them because the environment they
create
if you respect them would be one where
you would now just want to work out more
and so it's the same thing for your
dreams when you are not around the
people who are who are negative and who
are trapped and who are in a lot of pain
and when you add in people and content
that makes you feel alive and hope and
possibilities and belief great things
start to happen great things start to
happen but it has to be consistent a
one-off video is not enough
every day
put it into your calendar that whether
it's a human being that you're actually
talking to or content that you're
feeding into your mind
that you're going to show more belief in
yourself because your mission matters
because your heart matters because you
have a gift that the world needs and
because you want to create a new future
a better future for yourself for your
family for the world I was a good
student I never skipped class it was
more that I was probably afraid of
missing out on stuff and failing tests
so even though I have a lot of
entrepreneurial Tendencies I still I
still did you know pretty well in school
and showed up the classes and did the
assignments but I wasn't happy about it
and it felt especially the small
business class felt useless you know if
I'm taking economics classes and I'm
taking accounting classes
those felt a lot more practical than
that it would it would guide me towards
being an investment banker I had to I
had to have those classes on my on my
resume but the small business one just
felt like a giant waste of time think
about your own education experience most
of
high school college is just memorization
right you're just memorizing stuff it's
the connections to other people which
can be helpful and and then memorizing
you don't actually learn very much like
how much do you actually remember from
your your stats class or math class or
calculus or French or whatever like how
much did you actually most of it is just
memorization I'm not actually completely
anti-education it's just more uh through
your actions map to your Ambitions so if
you want to be an entrepreneur you're
going to get nothing pretty much from a
university of Education if you want to
be a doctor then you have to go off and
do it and it's not so much that you're
learning amazing things because you
could learn you can learn it in much
faster ways if you care about something
you're going to learn a lot more and if
you see it being practical and
applicable to your life you're going to
learn a lot faster I remember being in
stats class
and
uh statistics was super boring to me I
memorized a whole bunch of things in
formulas and never applied it didn't see
how this was relevant and so instantly
forgot it and then I was working on a I
have my own software company now and
tool that we're using and
we're split testing different thumbnails
one versus the other and I wanted to be
statistically significant and I remember
that term from my stats class like well
how do you calculate that again now that
it actually became applicable to me now
I'm suddenly interested in it and when
you care about something you're gonna
you're gonna be more interested in it
and you're gonna learn it and it'll
stick where most of the stuff that we
learn in school you just don't find it
relevant or helpful and so it doesn't
stick and so again there's much faster
ways to learn
it's caring about it it's being in the
community of other people who are
learning
um but the point of school is not to
learn the point of school is to get the
degree so you can get the job and if
that's what your goals are awesome you
still have to play that game and if it's
not your goals then
then how can you better achieve your
goals right and like get there's still
pressure and maybe your family's forcing
you to do it or you still think that in
the eyes of society that's the best
thing to do but man is as long as you're
making decisions based off of other
people's opinions you're never gonna win
you know if you're living your parents
version of your life or you're living
society's version of your life you're
just never gonna win that doesn't mean
that you just drop everything and you
know just throw it all away
but are you taking enough action and
enough steps towards building the thing
that you want to build and
maybe that means taking a year off maybe
that means taking a semester off maybe
that means starting your side hustle
like there's one thing just to complain
about a life that you don't like
but the more important thing is there
are you taking action the amount of
people who are complaining about the
thing that they're doing that they don't
enjoy but at the same time we're taking
zero action towards the thing they want
to do the thing that you claim you enjoy
or you spend enough time have you
scheduled it in are you is it in your
calendar that consistently you're taking
some kind of action towards the life
that you want to build or not for too
many people it's no you're just
complaining about a life that you don't
like about a school system that you
don't like about a job you don't like
you know about a relationship you don't
like but what are you doing to actually
fix it
and again it doesn't mean you have to
burn the boats and go all in and and you
know pour garbage all over your boss's
office or quit school right away right
it doesn't have to go all in right away
but you do have to take consistent
action towards building a life that you
do want I look at movement makers as an
example and that's my that's my training
program it's my mentorship program where
I every two weeks I get thought leaders
together who are trying to build build
their audience build their Community
they have a movement inside them that
they want us to get into the world and
so we talk about making videos and
winning on social media and getting book
deals and becoming a speaker and how do
you get that thing that's in your heart
you know how do you get that that
message here out to the world and we
meet every two weeks and it's the
greatest educational
thing out there for people who want to
become thought leaders right if you
don't want to be a thought leader you're
going to be bored and find it a waste of
time if you want to be a thought leader
it's the best thing in the world and
it's training with me but it's also
connection to community of other people
who are doing it so when you want to
learn something I look at them and
they're doing it and they're taking on
challenges and they're making videos and
all of a sudden now they're starting to
get an audience and starting to get
clients and building a business and
that's the best
you know it's the best
and the fact that they're not just doing
it by themselves but they're doing it
with other people that you're part of a
community when you're around other
people who are also learning learning is
one thing and going from education to
self-education like traditional
education formal education to
self-education becomes the game if you
want to learn right traditional
education the goal is not to learn the
goals to get a job cool that's your goal
awesome if you want to learn you have to
flip the model from traditional
education to self-education stop blaming
a traditional education system it's just
not designed to learn that's not what
you're there for
if you want to learn you have to create
your own self-education program you have
to go learn from the people who've done
the thing that you want to do model
success be around and take consistent
action and get some kind of community
because the learning amplifies when
you're when you're not doing it alone if
you feel like you're always alone
everything is on your shoulders nobody
around you understands nobody else is
trying to do something similar to you
you're isolated
um you don't feel like you belong that
that's really hard it's not that it's
not possible it's just insanely
difficult and most people will quit
along the way or at the very least just
not take enough consistent action but
when you're around other people who are
doing the thing who are also committed
who are learning who are you're teaching
each other and you feel like you're not
alone on the journey it's one of the
biggest improvements I made to movement
makers
was at the very very beginning it's 85
minutes every two weeks right so the
very beginning it was me teaching for 85
minutes because I thought you know what
got to get the education now to teach as
much informations in my brain pour it
into your brain let's go
and what I found was some of the best
elements that movement makers is having
them having the members connect to each
other
and creating breakout rooms for people
where they can share their experience
explain what what road they're on
creating a Discord where people can
share their wins get help from each
other so that's not all flowing through
me but then they're connected to each
other and when you can create a family
people who are also learning the same
thing that you're learning man when
you're around those kind of people
everything changes when it's not just
you pushing the ball uphill every single
day all by yourself everything changes
and so moving from traditional education
to self-education to actually if your
goal is to actually learn and then
finding a community a people who were
like-minded who are also chasing down
their goals and their dreams you get
that man the next year will be you'll be
unstoppable you'll be unrecognizable
like the person who you will be in one
year compared to who you are right now
you won't even recognize wow that's who
I used to be
that's how you turbocharge your growth
invest in self-education and get around
a community of like-minded people who
will push you forward when it's simple
you can go fast when it's simple when
you have Clarity when you've got
Direction that's so much easier to get
stuff done to actually make progress on
your goals but when you're stuck with
over complicating overthinking over
strategizing nothing happens you felt
this you've had ideas you've had goals I
have too dreams goals Ambitions desires
like here's what I want to do and then
what do we do what's the next step we
make it so big we start thinking of all
the possibilities of where it could go
and what could go wrong and we start
planning and overthinking and
researching and more planning and more
research and more and then as a result
nothing happens nothing happens because
we've now wasted days of just research
planning thinking and we've made it so
big that we feel like we can't do it by
ourselves anymore like now now we can't
get started because we need a team we
need money we need investors we need
promotion we need people to help us we
need we need we need we need all these
things we never actually make have you
been there I lost a 40 million deal when
I was 20 because of that
because of overthinking over planning
over preparing and not enough doing and
it's not that planning isn't important
it's just not the first step the first
step is to get really clear really
narrow really specific to this is what I
need to do and then going off and doing
it because you have time we feel like we
don't have time even if you have a job
you have family you have time the
problem is the time that you're spending
on your business is not intentional
enough is not simple enough it's not
clear enough and you spend your time
going in circles overthinking instead of
actually doing does that sound familiar
creating the environment for yourself
for Success so
you know if if best book bits inspires
you great look at the content every day
if this show inspires you great follow
Michael and look at the other stuff that
he's doing most of us don't have enough
people around us who are doing amazing
things chances are the people listening
to this show you're the most
ambitious person that you know
you're the most growth oriented you're
the one pouring in other people you're
the one saying this book I just read you
have to go read it you know we're we're
forcing our ideas on other people
because we've learned so much you've
learned so much and you just want to
share it with other people but the
people around you aren't as receptive
aren't as open aren't as growth minded
as you are and and that's a great gift
that you're giving them but the
challenge is you don't have people who
are pushing you and so I try to surround
myself with with the environment that
pushes me forward in the content that I
make because I want to be around Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and super
successful entrepreneurs because they
because they pulled me forward and so
the more that I'm around that the more I
want to believe in myself and go chase
my dreams so that's the first like your
environment your habits your routine are
you around the people who are lifting
you up either in person but more likely
online or through books that inspire you
as part of your daily routine not just a
one-off thing that you happen to do the
biggest hack to stop caring about other
people's opinions to stop living other
people's version of your life and to
start actually feeling happy and proud
of yourself the biggest hack to doing
that is to figure out what you stand for
to figure out your single most important
core value I believe that everybody has
a single most important core value and
when you figure that out it gives you a
lot more clarity a lot more Direction a
lot more confidence and allows you to
start to to do things that you never
thought were possible all of a sudden
that idea that you've gotta oh my gosh I
could do this thing but then never take
an action on it things start to happen
for you because you have that Clarity of
value so I wrote two books on this your
one word and built to serve and we go
through the process of figuring out your
one word or your who who are you what do
you stand for what is that single most
important core value
one of my favorite activities that I go
through I call it the five essential
questions but the most important one
there I find usually is asking people
who is your favorite teacher growing up
and why
so if you've understood the concept of
hey I need I need to have a core value I
need to know what I stand for I'm tired
of being on on quicksand I'm tired of
living other people's version of my life
okay great how do I figure it out
do I just pick one at random do I just
you read a book like how do I actually
figure out what I stand for well
asking yourself that question who your
favorite teacher growing up was and why
I think it's critical think about it
you've had how many teachers in your
life think about your school elementary
school high school uh University if you
went to a college other teachers you've
had
you've had lots of teachers growing up
and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walk past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they were
because they had no impact
but there's always that one teacher that
stood out
there's one teacher that stood out for
you
why it wasn't because they taught you
grade 8 math is because they made you
feel different as a human
they gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
fart
but I'm far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely use French
and on a day-to-day basis
what she taught me was to believe in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of of uh
High School
and she would meet with me every week
Force before school started once a week
we'd sit down we'd chat we'd talk about
life we talk about school we talk about
where I was at we talked about what was
on my mind
and in those conversations she made me
feel like I could I could do more
that I that her belief in me created
more belief in myself
and in that last year I went from being
a b and c student to straight 90s
straight A Plus
[Music]
I was still the same guy I still had the
same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had
it was just that belief in me that she
gave me that allowed me to go off and
start to perform more
so I think that's the most important
question you can ask another one you can
look at is what was your favorite movie
growing up and why
so what's your favorite movie of all
time why there's so many movies that
you've watched most of them you don't
remember but there's one that that
sticks out that really stands out for
you in some in some way for some reason
my favorite movie is Seabiscuit it's
about this horse that is way too small
it's about this jockey that's way too
big it's about this owner that's
bankrupt and somehow they all find each
other and start winning a whole bunch of
races when when they they shouldn't be
you know and it's based off of a true
story and it ended up lifting a nation
that people love this Underdog Story and
it's a story of belief same thing
it's a story of belief
we all at least for me I love the idea
of being that Seabiscuit or being the
jockey or being the owner and helping
not just each other believe in
themselves but also the nation
for the audience for the fans helping
them believe in themselves
and so if you started asking those
questions if you started thinking about
who are the people that make you come
alive that make you feel like you're a
better person and what are the resources
or what are the YouTube channels or
Instagram accounts or books or podcasts
or shows what are the things that have
made you come alive what are the things
that have made you feel
like you could do more
and then next to each one write down a
couple of words so your favorite teacher
growing up who was it and then why three
words to explain why your favorite movie
of all time
and then three words why and what you'll
find is as you do this exercise
you'll see some similar patterns you'll
see some words pop off the page you'll
see that same word come up a couple
times
that's your who
that's your single most important core
value
that's what you still need more of in
your life right now and that's what you
want to give to the world
the other great part about it is that
will be with you for life this isn't
something that we want to change this is
who you are this is your best version of
you
at my core I'm I'm the best when I
believe in myself and my biggest problem
is still I need to believe in myself
more to get to the next level
when you figure out your most important
core value your who your one word
biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level
and it's what you want to give to the
people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big message
but some people like Nina who was just
here she doesn't have a big message but
she wants to help the closest people to
her
we all want to feel like what we do
matters we all want to feel like we're
having an impact on people whether the
closest people to us or to the world but
we're stuck and we're lost and we need
guidance and if you feel like you have
all these ideas but you don't know how
they all make sense
and you don't know that
you feel like it could be something but
you don't know how to get there
there's not enough momentum happening
because you're not in touch with your
single most important core value
here's an example
if I'm struggling to do something I'm
struggling to get on stage to speak I'm
struggling to turn on the camera to make
a video for you I'm struggling to launch
my next project you know I get an idea
and then I say I can't do that
what do I need
at the end of the day what I really need
like what's the thing that's going to
turn that idea into actual action
I do more belief
and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no when I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
believe more on yourself
because that's at the core of who I am
and when I can catch it then it gives me
the courage to go off and do it to
record the video to get on stage she
launch that project to say yes to say
yes to say yes I think of uh Alex who
helps me run Toronto dance salsa his who
was belong
he needs to belong more with himself and
he needs to spread more belong to the
world
and whenever he's not happy and whenever
he's not following through and whenever
he's not hitting his goals and doing the
work it's because he doesn't feel like
he belongs doesn't feel like he belongs
to himself and he doesn't feel like he's
spreading belong to the world if you are
stuck
if you are going too slow
if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you
thing that is missing
is you not following through on who you
say you want to be you're not matching
that potential
how you make it practical
to figure out your who
because every time you come back to that
and say I just need more of X I need
more hope I need more freedom I need
more belief I need more belong I need
more love I need more care for myself
and then to spread it to the world
and when you can feel that
when you can actually
it'll dramatically change how you show
up
all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a year
the chains you've given yourself wings
you've given yourself the permission to
actually go off and do the scary thing
that's inside you because now you know
who you are
figure out your one word figure out your
who watch your life change most people
don't get what they want because you
don't follow through enough you just
don't follow through it's based out of
insecurity you start and stop start and
stop you're afraid of hurting people's
feelings you're afraid of what they're
gonna say about you you're afraid
they're gonna judge you and
we're afraid of having that L on our
personal resume and so we we stop we
stop and try to do something else where
we're seeing more immediate results but
if it's your goal if it's your dream you
have to follow through one of my
favorite stores is Brendan burchard and
I went to speak at his event in Phoenix
and I knew of him but I didn't know him
at the time it was his business partner
that had me come out to his event
and hired me to speak there and that's
where I met Brendan for the first time
and he asked me hey what are you working
on what can I help or you know what's
next for you and I said I won't work on
my book and he said I'd love to uh I'd
love to help I'd love to give you some
feedback on your book like I am
definitely down for that
let's connect and uh he's he asked me
what my phone number was and at the time
I didn't have a phone I didn't use a
phone uh number and I said how about
email and he said oh I'm not really good
on email but if that's the only way then
let's do email so we exchanged emails
and uh I didn't I didn't hear from him
so I I followed up and I said hey
Brendan thank you you know great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then he said
oh man thank you uh I'm super swamped
right now but uh let's see they're due
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head every time I sent another
email I I was questioning myself I was
judging myself like oh I don't want to
bother him
um maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out uh maybe
I'm offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
he's just a busy guy he had a lot of
stuff going on he had a launch that was
happening that I wasn't even aware of uh
that he was planning behind the scenes
and so he is he was you know not crazy
stressed out but he just has a lot on
his plate that he's dealing with and
it's hard to tell ourselves that it's
easier to default to the insecurity of
maybe you're bothering maybe you're
asking too much maybe you're not worthy
maybe you should move on the event that
he talked about me coming to was coming
up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
uh just one more email that's it I'm
gonna send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and um hopefully you know he doesn't
think I'm a loser or whatever
and he wrote back an email and like hey
sorry man again I'm not super great on
email just been swamped planning all
these things uh yeah come on out come
out to the event speak at the event too
and that was his big event that was you
know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind to
be a part of that then I spoke on stage
that then at the event after I spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Lewis house and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses all of
that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up but I followed up
and I followed up and I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence and and I and the reasons
why you're not doing it are based in
reality right I mean I could be
overwhelming it's it's possible it's
possible that he thinks that I'm
overwhelming that I'm not given enough
value that I'm being too selfish that
I'm bothering him I mean it's possible
but we default to just assuming that
instead of actually finding out
and we miss out on a lot of upside and
so here's what I found that really helps
one you schedule it in
you schedule it in every X number of
weeks right so every two weeks I would
send in another email every two weeks
every two weeks every two weeks every
two weeks every two weeks every two
weeks and I never felt like doing it
because every time I saw that in my task
list
I I didn't want to do it like you know
let's give it another let's give it
another few days let's give it another
week you know I never wanted to do it
but because it was in my calendar I did
it
you will never want to do it because
you're afraid right underneath it is
really just fear it's insecurity you'll
never want to do it so you schedule it
in every two weeks or every week or
every month or whatever the thing is
that makes sense to the timeline that
you're on
schedule it in so that you have to do it
so when it came up I knew I had even
though I didn't want to even though my
heart was beaten like
I still went off and I did it second
thing is
lead with the intention before you write
the email before you make the call
before you do the follow-up like what's
the intention is your intention to screw
this person over is your intention to
just suck up their time is your
intention to negotiate a bad deal for
them hopefully not
if you're if you're a subscriber of this
channel uh hopefully it's with its
positivity and hope and belief and and
mutual you know uh benefits and so if
you lead with that intention every time
it's really unlikely that they're going
to
come back in a really negative way
the truth of the matter is they're
probably just really busy maybe they're
doing something
insane in their life maybe they have a
health scare maybe they're in the
hospital maybe their mom's in the
hospital right like you never know
what's going on behind the scenes
and if you leave with intention as
opposed to a copy paste email or just
some kind of spam if you if you leave
with I love this person I want to do
something with them I want to help I I
want to I want to learn like if that's a
positive intention going in your your
call your email your follow-up will just
be a lot better it'll be a lot better
and people will feel it I forget who it
was I want to say it was
ah no I forget who it is I'm thinking
princess dive I don't think it was her I
wanna I don't forget who it was where
she would say before I send an email
I would always smile
I would think about the person
and I would smile before I I wrote an
email wrote a letter
and it would always change
the the vibe of the letter right like if
you're thinking love kindness smiling
before you make a video before you do a
DM before you do a uh an email right
like if you're thinking that
yeah
chances are you'll make them smile
you know like if you're smiling
before you do it you're probably gonna
make them smile
and so just taking that little pause to
reflect on what is my intention here
instead of defaulting to insecurity and
the stress on your side
default into let's lead with positivity
let's smile let's leave with love
you'd be amazed at how many great things
happen
so those two things
one you put in your calendar
until you get a response like if
somebody if somebody says no
okay
at least you got a response
but again it's likely going to be a
loving no because you followed up so
many times and you've always LED with a
positive intention and love and kindness
they might just say I'm just you know
what I can't do this right now or I'm
not interested or
or hey sorry I haven't gotten back to
you let's do this
right A lot of times it's just a timing
a lot of times your timing is way off
and it's not your timing it just doesn't
fit into their life or their world right
now but in two weeks it might or in two
months it might or in two years it might
and if you're following up every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks and you're leading with
love and kindness and with a positive
intent amazing things will happen
you have a great Mission inside you
you have a desire to serve and the help
and to create great things for the
people who you work with right like that
that is at the core of Who You Are
and that needs to be spread
and at the beginning when people don't
know who you are it's a little harder to
get attention to get on people's radar
but if you are consistently following
through consistently even in the face of
not getting any response you just
consistently because it's on your
calendar you're consistently following
through and you're leading with the
intention of Love kindness positivity
great things will happen
I promise you great things will happen
the biggest fear we have isn't failure
you're not afraid of failing the biggest
fear we have is of failing in front of
other people you're afraid of people's
judgments the reason why we stay stuck
the reason why you still are where you
are is because you're afraid of other
people's opinions you have
great ideas inside you you have great
ideas if you're watching this video
You're subscribed to this channel you
have great ideas you know you're capable
of more you know you want to serve you
know you want to help
and great ideas are flowing through you
and we shut them off
you shut them off because we find a
logical reason why we can't do it right
the logical reasons in our head are well
the timing's not right or I don't have
the gear right on the connections or uh
you know I'm in the wrong country or
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's that's listen it's based in
reality it's actually based in fact
because you wouldn't you're a smart
person you wouldn't believe a stupid
reason
so the reasons that we're listening to
are actually based on some kind of fact
but there's still an excuse and
underneath it underneath that reason why
you can't do something is because you're
afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underlined that is not the fear of it
not working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you
fail
we're so tied up into what other people
think about us that we'd rather play
small for life than actually go off and
accomplish and risk failing in front of
other people we're so afraid of that
that we never go off and
chase our dreams down and you're stuck
in this mental exercise of what you
could do
and then never actually doing anything
my biggest fear of disappointing people
you know it's that's still fear of
judgment it's still fear of I'm gonna
show up and speak in an event and it's
just not going to go well that people
will
be unhappy with my speech and I put
crazy amount of pressure on myself and
in my head I think people are here and
if I struggle then the whole thing is
ruined right I remember I was speaking
at printable shards event and uh it was
in Puerto Rico and people are paying
tons of money to be here you know it was
a 30 to 50 000 Mastermind and
everybody's got giant businesses right
these are multi-million dollar
businesses owners who are in the house
and it was a multiple Day event I think
it was a three-day event and I'm I'm
speaking for one of them not even a
whole day I'm speaking I have one I've
got an hour or something of time right
at that event
in my head it's if I suck on stage then
people will freak out and be unhappy and
say this was a total waste of event
we're really
tiny nothing part of this event
Char the scene Dean graziozi to see the
other speakers there if any one speaker
sucks I mean if Brendan sucked that's a
big deal because he's speaking for 80 of
the time if I suck for one hour nobody's
really gonna care nobody's really gonna
be asking for a refund but
even though that's the the actual answer
it's not the it's not the thing that's
in my head and that's what we need to
fight that's what we need to fight
because I used to say no to
Opportunities because I was really deep
down just afraid that I would not be
able to deliver
I remember that I used to secretly hope
people would cancel on me
I would I would secretly hope that
interviews with cancer on me the
meetings would cancel on me
um I remember I would book something out
like it's two months in advance right I
don't know if this has ever happened to
you this this makes sense or if it's
happened to you let me know in the
comments
I would book something out that was a
month in advance or two months in
advance and so yeah I'm like that's
exciting I'm happy to do that and then
on the day of I look at my calendar and
say oh that's coming up and I would
secretly hope I would check my email I
remember I'd be checking my email hoping
that that person would cancel on me to
say oh I'm busy or I got sick or it's
not going to work out anymore and let's
reschedule and I remember I check in the
morning and I checked two hours of four
and check an hour before and check half
an hour before and check 10 minutes
before and like if there was no email
then then I would go ahead and do it
so I'm losing insane amounts of
productivity right like how many times
am I checking my email before this thing
happens lose an insane productivity and
also not actually serving right not
actually living my mission my message
not not actually being proud of myself
for what I'm doing and it it almost
always worked out like I never had an
interview or a meeting or something
where I just massively underperformed
and actually sucked right that that
never really happened but I was always
afraid of it happening
and so I had to teach myself
this is what I want to do like the only
thing worse than me not doing this
is is me doing this and canceling right
or them me never doing an interview and
me never doing a meeting
and just recognizing that it was just
fear talking and again the fears of me
disappointing people and feeling in
front of somebody else
I'm sitting here filming in in the car
Nina just came back we love you Nina
Nina's uh doing some grocery shopping
and I'm I'm filming here you know in the
car we got the dogs here in the back
seat timo's chilling and this used to
make me afraid you know that look
there's a guy who just pulled up next to
me
he's not watching but in my head you'd
be like this guy's watching
you have to be afraid of filming in a
parking lot be afraid of filming uh
walking down the street I'd be afraid of
filming with my sister in the room you
know I used to be afraid of all of that
so what is that
it's just fear of other people's
opinions why am I afraid of this guy
why I'm afraid of that guy I don't know
that guy
right
why am I afraid of him and his opinion
first off he doesn't even care right
he's not even looking at me he doesn't
even care maybe he never even noticed
that I was filming period right so we
think people care they don't care
on the off chance that he actually cares
uh maybe he is judging me and thinks I'm
crazy holding this camera up with with
the tripod in my hand maybe he thinks
I'm crazy great uh if somebody's leading
with that then then they hate their own
life like if somebody's leading with
just negative judgment he's got his own
issues to deal with that have nothing to
do with me or maybe he's inspired maybe
maybe this guy goes look he pulled out
his phone maybe he's making his own
YouTube video maybe he's inspired maybe
that guy is now going to be the next
YouTube sensation let's go
so we assume that everybody's gonna
watch us everybody's only looking at us
and
and we're gonna disappoint and be a
giant failure and everybody's gonna
laugh for me to kill us right like
that's the thought that's that's in our
head where the reality is most people
don't care
most people right like 90 of people
don't even care
five percent of people might judge you
and they're in a really negative spot
themselves and the other five percent
maybe they're inspired by you and they
see that and they go and do something
with their life
but you playing small and listen to that
fear instead of actually taking some
kind of action will always lead to a
negative spot like you know that you
could do more you want to do more you
want to serve on a bigger scale but
listening to that fear
instead is keeping you stuck this is one
of the biggest problems for
entrepreneurs is that you you have all
these great ideas that are flowing
through you right you've got you've got
an endless list of ideas how big is your
list of things that you could do that
you get excited by when you look at them
and then how many are you actually doing
well not very many you're missing the
momentum because at the end of the day
you can write down a list of all these
reasons why it can't work out and and
when the timing is going to be just
right and perfect right I'll start this
on January 1st or start this next month
or next week or Monday or on my birthday
or some artificial day you come up with
some reason of when you should be
starting this thing right but if you
actually examined it if you actually
took a little step back and looked at
your goals that you haven't hit that you
haven't started that just remain an idea
and you've never taken momentum on if
you actually took five minutes to step
back from it create a little distance
and look at them and look at your list
of reasons why you haven't started
really it's just fear
and when you can catch that
that's when you make a life-changing
decision
because as long as you are
not chasing down the things that you
want to do because you're afraid of
somebody else's Judgment of you as long
as that is a thing that rules you you
will never win you will never accomplish
anything great and you'll you'll live
life with regret so even now my my
biggest fear is still disappointing
people
and the ongoing challenge is to catch it
and when you can catch it and when you
can know BS
catch it to say I'm just throwing up a
bunch of excuses but really I'm just
afraid when you can catch it
then
summon the courage to go do the
difficult thing summon the courage to
say I'm gonna I'm gonna take this fear
head on
because as long as that fear runs your
life
you stay stuck
and every time you catch the fear and
you do it because of not just feel the
fear and do it anyway Feel the fear and
do it because of
you start to teach yourself to be a
little stronger a little more courageous
and you move a little bit closer to
becoming the person that you are capable
of being to change your life you have to
be willing to change your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must
Abel be willing
otherwise you will stay stuck forever I
was doing an Instagram live yesterday
with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say
I'm not comfortable doing that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of this what it is you're
afraid of being judged and so we're not
comfortable doing that thing you'll
you'll fail if nobody else sees it if
it's just you but you don't want to fail
in front of other people and that can no
longer be a good enough reason because
if you only do think about this if you
only do what's comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did was wake up and
do what's in your comfort zone do what
is known do what is comfortable do what
do what you've always done you're gonna
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs is you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
it's actually the opposite because you
are uncomfortable doing it now you have
to do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I had to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was a big aha moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is a thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use that as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountable said you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
against your value system right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I wanted to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 we had 23
cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour and instead
of just doing a small tour of three
cities or something like 23 cities 90
days you know a quarter of the year on
the road straight with with my wife and
my cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things the willingness to show up even
if you don't win
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
insert to accomplish your goals and so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today looked the same as yesterday look
the day is the day before same as the
day before is why most people do not
like their life is why most people drive
to a job that they hate
they're driving to a job that they hate
most people wake up all you know look at
all these cars here most people here in
this parking lot they're picking up
every day and driving to a job that they
hate they do not like their life most of
the people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something what's the
goal of yours that you've been sitting
on and then what's the voice in your
head that that's giving you an
acceptable reason for you not to do the
thing
now try to get to the reason behind the
reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I know the time I don't have the
camera I don't have the gear I don't
want the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is gonna be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we're afraid of when people won't watch
it and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone
bad camera bad microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
of failure if it's fear of not being
good enough if this fear of being
imposter if it's fear of being
uncomfortable whatever your actual fear
is that's your trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome pretend
more amazing rules from Brendan burchard
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if the people
around you tend to be healthy whether
that is emotionally healthy mentally
healthy physically healthy your odds go
way up especially the odds of
conscientious discipline and design your
ability to